for joseph r biden of delaware
a democrat eyes 55
knows zero
california's electoral college vote made
it official joe biden is the
president-elect
and in the end the formal tally of the
states joe biden won in the november
election
was the procedural affair it normally is
across the country electors and states
that biden flipped from the republicans
cast their state's votes for the
president-elect joseph r biden has
received 16 votes
under the u.s constitution the president
isn't chosen by the popular vote but by
the 538 electors of the electoral
college
however usually they follow the majority
vote in each of their states
as part of the trump campaign's efforts
to overturn the election results
efforts were made to subvert that
process the electors have unanimously
cast
16 votes for joseph r biden but even in
michigan one of several states where
electors were given a police escort
the vote was conducted without surprise
and
eventually 306 electors across the
country voted for biden
232 for trump soon after joe biden made
a national address
calling for the page to be turned 306
electoral votes is the same number of
electoral votes
that donald trump and vice president
pence
received when they won in 2016. excuse
me
at the time president trump called as
elect the electoral college
tally a landslide by his own standards
these numbers represented a clear
victory then
and i respectfully suggest they do so
now
if nothing else some wonder whether this
rare focus on the electoral college
might lead to more discussion about
whether u.s voters should be allowed
directly to vote for president
i myself disagree that we still need an
electoral college to certify
our election results and we should
really live into our principle in this
country of one person one vote
and make sure that we honor the popular
vote when americans vote
for president on election day as the
electoral college finalized biden's
victory throughout the day
trump tweeted about election fraud he
has repeated he will fight on in the
courts
though it's not clear what his
motivation is at this point the
electoral college votes will now be sent
to the u.s
congress where they will be counted and
certified on january the
6th there are reports that some
republicans may attempt a
last-ditch stand at that point which if
nothing else will be
a symbolic moment that will help a
narrative that many
trump supporters still believe that this
election has been stolen however the
polls
also show that a majority of americans
do feel that it's time to move on
shia britancy al jazeera wilmington
delaware
well steve clements is the washington
editor at large for the hill and host of
al jazeera is the bottom line he says
it's now impossible for anyone in the
republican party to deny
biden's victory today was the day
and we've seen major senators like
senator roy blunt senator john thune who
had
really held out and had suspicions
himself that he expressed about
the solvency of the election came out
and said it's time for this to end
uh joe biden is going to be the
president and they're coming around so
we've had a good number of republican
senators just today
come out and say that they now recognize
joe biden as the president-elect
so i i think what's going to happen i
mean we all you know we're in the
business of speculating here and i want
to let the audience know i'm speculating
is that i think that that that number of
people whether they're senators or
members of the house of representatives
even those house members that signed the
uh the legal brief to the supreme court
they're beginning to look like you know
comic acts if you will and i think
you're going to find
the number of those people peel away
because there's just no way
no serious way to consider
constitutionally
how to undo the votes of electors
americans don't vote for the president
of the united states directly
they vote for electors and those
electors from states
elect the president of the united states
that occurred today it will of course be
certified on january 6 but the election
happened today
and we all know how it came out and what
the numbers are so i think
other members will see it and if they
don't come along with that
because they fear what donald trump may
do to them in donald trump's
you know after life uh in in the
post-presidency
uh then i think they're going to become
fringe politicians and fringe in the
eyes of the uh
a lot of americans